Now we're going to cover another area important to
use when you're writing data, we're going to talk
about transactions. Let's go back and look at a
user registering to attend a conference for example. As
you may recall, we previously introduced an ancestor relationship
between a profile and conference where the profile that
created a conference was the ancestor to the conference.
We will now introduce a "has-a" relationship between profile and
conference where each profile entity will have a
list of conferences they will attend. We will call
this property "conferences to attend". In addition, we will
have a numeric counter in each conference entity which
specifies how many seats are still available, we
will call this property "seats available". So when a
user registers to attend a conference, the conference gets
added to conferences to attend and seats available gets
decremented by one. So going back to transactions, in
this case your application will perform two update operations
on two separate entities. So far, every data store
update operation we used have been independent of the other.
For example, the success or failure of put entity
1 and put entity 2 has been independent of
the success and failure of the other. This may
be okay in many situations but in many situations it
may also be completely unacceptable. So going back
to transactions, in this case your application will perform
two update operations on two separate entities. On the
profile entity, you will add the conference to the
conferences to attend property and on the conference
entity it will decrement the seats available counter. All
of these operations are performed independently in these diagram
right now, you may see that they are highly
dependent on each other. Imagine, for example, that
you have successfully added the conference to the
profile entity and then the unthinkable happens. Your
application needs to terminate for some reason. For example,
it runs out of memory and is faced
with a critical termination condition. In this case,
when your application restarts the profile entity will
have the conference registered to attend but the seats
available counter has not be decremented. This
means that there will be more users attending
than there are seats available. That is not good, we solve this problem by using
transactions. This is done by telling data
store to begin a transaction. Then you perform
your operations and finally, you commit your transaction.
If everything goes well, you have successfully performed
both update operations and the state of both
account have been updated. In transaction language, we call
this a commit forward. But if the unthinkable
happens and something goes wrong before we have successfully
executed the commit transaction statement then anything that
has been updated starting from the begin statement will
be undone, like it has never happened. For our
case that means that the seats available counter was
not decremented but it also means that
the conference was not added to the profile
entity. As you can see we have
created a mutual dependency between these statements. They
are either executed as a complete group or none of it gets done. Now the
time has come for you to add
transactions to conference central with a new exercise.